marriage from a legal standpoint what we
mean when we say I got married
is it is a is a state agency it's been
created by the state like this is a a
legal status
that most people who are in it know
nothing about
they they just did the most legally
significant thing they're ever going to
do other than dying
and they have no idea
what rights and obligations it created
in them and the first time they're going
to get an education about it is in my
office that's crazy when they get
divorced that's crazy and so prenup is
an opportunity to learn something about
it at the start so first of all it
whenever someone approaches me about
prenups and and that's like four or five
times a week probably depending on the
season right before wedding season we
get a lot like when's wedding season
well it used to just be the summer you
know say they say when you marry in June
you're a bride all your life that's from
some Rogers and Hammerstein musical
um now the fall is very big too people
love fall content fall weddings pretty
you know pictures and things yeah good
on the Ground full of content yeah all
right
weddings is for the gram I have to tell
you weddings is performative man see the
problem is though it's curated so you
you'd say here's us picking the cake
it's not here's us doing the prenup you
know how many you know how many people
I've done prenups for that I've watched
on their social media or them being
interviewed by Andy Cohen on Bravo and
saying well no we don't have a prenup
yeah you do yeah you do you do it's in
my office it's in a folder yeah I know
that's beautiful but prenups are not
published any place they're not filed
with a court they're maintained by the
two people that signed it and they're
lawyers that's it so nobody has to admit
that they have a premium beautiful but
it's but there's a yes but there's a
certain problem with that in so far is a
lot of people have prenups and we need
to normalize prenups like there's no
reason not to normalize prenups there's
no reason not for for until some famous
people say yeah we have a prenup we're
crazy about each other that's why we're
getting married you know but yeah look
we're getting you know I don't want to
get a car accident but I got a seat belt
you know like you have it just in case
and uh I mean what do you do if you're
running a company
like how what does that have to do with
the prenup you know you're running a 100
billion dollar or trillion dollar
company Jeff Bezos
I suppose his marriage was before Amazon
yeah as was before it was anything but
like how does that work in a prenup like
well no actually it's it's the same I
mean what you're
what you're doing with the prenup is
you're identifying
you're identifying how things will be
classified in advance so you're creating
a set of rules
and then you both can function under
those rules during the marriage so like
I for a brief time I taught a a family
law drafting class at a law school
and when we would do separation
agreements we would do pleadings you
know it was lots of fun when we would do
prenups I would say to the students you
know what's the main thing you need when
you're doing a prenup and they would say
well you know you need asset disclosure
and say well that's not the main thing
and he said well you need
um you know technical language I said
nope main thing you need is a crystal
ball
the main thing you need is the ability
to see what's going to happen in the
future who's going to have money who's
not who's going to be successful who
isn't what people will inherit problem
is we don't have that we don't have that
so what can we do we can create tranches
we can create structures we can create
systems
and then people can live with those in
mind you enter the game knowing the
rules right
so
you know if this is going to be a
submission only event you know if this
is going to be no time limit you know if
we're after certain number of minutes
we're going into points now okay so I
can work with that rule set and I'm
going to amend my game based on that
rule set
same thing same thing you're just going
to say look what's the rule set let's
agree on the rule set and then let's
conduct ourselves with the rule set in
mind let's plan the rule set in mind
and I think that you know and by the way
and if you're gonna cheat you cheat with
the rule set in mind you know you're
cheating right you know you're trying to
get around the rule set
so prenups
are when I do a consult for a prenup the
first thing I do is here's what's going
to happen legally if you marry without a
prenup
here's what happens to your rights and
obligations
then
what we can change with that there's
almost no limit you can you can amend
anything you want to the example I
always give is there was a case that
went up to the Appellate Court where
High net worth guy married a very
beautiful woman and there was a
provision in the prenuptial agreement
that said for every 10 pounds she gained
during the marriage she would lose ten
thousand dollars a month in alimony if
they divorced
and there was here's a baseline weight
as of the time of execution of this
agreement and I wondered if she was like
a like did like what a wrestler does
like did she like you know yeah did she
like right before and then cut when she
eventually got divorced like is she in
there with sauna you know with the suit
on
um but but the and the Appellate Court
essentially said
um I don't know why you married this
person having had them make you sign
this but it's binding yeah but it's fine
I wish somebody would do a contract like
that like like the rent for this place
would be more expensive if I was fatter
and cheaper if I was skinnier and that
way I would have to weigh in
motivation like some motivation on you
yeah exactly that's that kind of prenup
is motivating well what's his name I
think Tim Ferriss says that about how he
does like um
he said you should make Bets with people
like it's like if you gain this much I
got to give you this amount of money you
know I think he says that in one of his
early books and trying to make it
binding somehow which is tough yeah I
think when we create incentives of that
kind you know that's why like there was
like the no not November or No Shave
November you know sober like all this
yeah it was a competition when people
make a competition of something they
gamify something it you know makes it
something that people are more likely to
stick with so I mean I guess the prenup
be interesting there you know the
problem is there there's also
people put in prenups what's called
Fidelity Clauses uh oh yeah yeah it was
yeah Fidelity Clauses and people still
do these I discourage people from doing
them they're the two things that people
put in prenups that I discourage people
from putting in prenups but very often
people still put in prenups even with my
caveat is Fidelity Clauses and sunset
clauses
so Fidelity Clauses is
um I'm waving alimony I'm waving this
I'm waving that but if you cheat
I get a million bucks or I get this much
alimony or I get this amount and I know
the intention is to disincentivize the
person from cheating it's a deterrent to
have them cheat but all it really does
is just creates like an interesting
legal battle for lawyers like how did
you prove that they cheated or not all
right because uh what what yeah what
constitutes cheating also right right is
an emotional affair and Affair is oral
sex cheating is you know like what what
is and by the way how do you prove it
yeah like well I was in a hotel with her
but how do you prove that I had sex with
her you know like and it's it's very
very
um you're opening a can of worms with
that kind of a thing but people
sometimes still put them in
um and sunset Clauses Sunset Clauses is
if we're married X period of time this
goes away as if it never existed and why
is that a bad idea the same reason the
community property law in California is
a bad idea so the community property law
is after a certain number of years I
think it's seven
everything including your pre-marital
property all becomes marital property
and the idea of that was supposed to be
that if you've been married that number
of years like you're in enough of a
serious relationship now that everything
is one unit you're one person what it
actually does is creates a very
uncomfortable thought experiment that
people have to have at the six year mark
because you have to now the honeymoon's
kind of over you might have a kid or two
and you go okay wait a minute am I so
happy in this relationship
that I'm willing to take all of my
pre-marital assets and throw them in the
pot right now because if not I got six
months to get divorced yeah like and
that's not so like if you say to someone
like if you got married tomorrow
and then you found a company that's
worth a hundred million dollars
and under your prenup that's your
separate property
but there's a sunset Clause that says
that your prenup goes out the window in
15 years man at year 14 and six months
you gotta ask yourself some serious
questions about where's this
relationship going to be in five ten
years it's brilliant and that's why kids
you pay for a lawyer that's it we get
paid to see around corners you know I
get paid to be paranoid I tell people
that all the time